so i'd like to talk about the
development of human potential and i'd
like to start with
maybe the most impactful modern story
of development many of you here have
probably heard of the ten thousand hours
rule maybe you even model your own life
after it basically it's the idea
that to become great in anything takes
ten thousand hours of focused practice
so you'd better get started as early as
possible the poster child
for this story is tiger woods his father
famously gave him a putter when he was
seven months old
at ten months he started imitating his
father's swing
at two you can go on youtube and see him
on national television
fast forward to the age of 21 he's the
greatest golfer in the world
quintessential ten thousand dollar story
another that features in a number of
best-selling books is that of the three
poger sisters whose father decided to
teach them chess in a very technical
manner from a very early age
and really he wanted to show that with a
head start in focused practice any child
could become a genius in anything
and in fact two of his daughters went on
to become grandmaster chess players
so when i became the science writer at
sports illustrated magazine i got
curious
if this 10 000 hours rule is correct
then we should see that elite athletes
get a head start
in so-called deliberate practice this is
coached
error correction focused practice not
just playing around
and in fact when scientists study elite
athletes they see that they spend more
time
in deliberate practice not a big
surprise when they actually track
athletes over the course of their
development the pattern looks like this
the future elites actually spend less
time early on
in deliberate practice in their eventual
sport they tend to have what scientists
call a sampling period where they try a
variety of physical activities
they gain broad general skills they
learn about their interests and
abilities and delay
specializing until later than peers who
plateau at lower levels
and so when i saw that i said gosh that
doesn't really comport with the ten
thousand dollars rule does it
so i started to wonder about other
domains that we associate with
obligatory early specialization
like music turns out the pattern's often
similar
this is research from a world-class
music academy and what i want to draw
your attention to is this
the exceptional musicians didn't start
spending more time in deliberate
practice than the average musicians
until their third
instrument they too tended to have a
sampling period even musicians we think
of as famously precocious like yo-yo ma
he had a sampling period he just went
through it more rapidly than most
musicians do
nonetheless this research is almost
entirely ignored
and much more impactful is the first
page of the book battle him of the tiger
mother
where the author recounts assigning her
daughter violin
nobody seems to remember the part later
in the book where her daughter turns to
her and says you picked it
not me and largely quits so having seen
this sort of surprising pattern
in sports and music i started to wonder
about domains that affect even more
people like education
an economist found a natural experiment
in the higher ed systems of england and
scotland
in the period he studied the systems
were very similar except in england
students had to specialize in their
mid-teen years to pick a specific course
of study to apply towards in scotland
they could keep trying things in
university if they wanted to and his
question was
who wins the trade-off the early or the
late specializers and what he saw was
that the early specializers jump out to
an income lead because they have more
domain specific skills
the late specializers get to try more
different things and when they do pick
they have better fit or what economists
call match quality
and so their growth rates are faster by
six years out they erase that income gap
meanwhile the early specializers start
quitting their career tracks in much
higher numbers
essentially because they were made to
choose so early that they more often
made poor choices
so the late specializers lose in the
short term and win in the long run
i think if we thought about career
choice like dating we might not pressure
people to settle down quite so quickly
so this got me interested seeing this
pattern again in exploring the
developmental backgrounds of people
whose work i had long admired
like duke ellington who shunned music
lessons as a kid to focus on baseball
and painting and drawing
or mariam mirzahni who wasn't interested
in math as a girl dreamed of becoming a
novelist
and went on to become the first and so
far only woman to win the fields medal
the most prestigious prize in the world
in math
vincent van gogh had five different
careers each of which he deemed his true
calling
before flaming out spectacularly and in
his late 20s picked up a book called the
guide to the abcs of drawing
that worked out okay claude shannon was
an electrical engineer at the university
of michigan who took a philosophy course
just to fulfill a requirement
and in it he learned about a near
century-old system of logic
by which true and false statements could
be coded as ones and zeros and solved
like math problems
this led to the development of binary
code which underlies all of our digital
computers today
finally my own sort of role model
francis hesselbein this is me
with her she took her first professional
job at the age of 54.
went on to become the ceo of the girl
scouts which she saved
she tripled minority membership added
130
000 volunteers and this is one of the
proficiency badges that came out of her
tenure it's binary code for girls
learning about computers
today francis runs a leadership
institute where she works every weekday
in manhattan
and she's only 104 so who knows what's
next
we never really hear developmental
stories like this do we don't hear about
the research that found that nobel
laureate scientists
are 22 times more likely to have a hobby
outside of work as our typical
scientists we never hear that
even when the performers of the work is
very famous we don't hear these
developmental stories for example here's
an athlete
i've followed here he is at age six
wearing a scottish rugby kit
now he tried some tennis some skiing
wrestling his mother was actually a
tennis coach but she declined to coach
him because he wouldn't return balls
normally
he did some basketball table tennis
swimming when his coaches wanted to move
him up a level
to play with older boys he declined
because he just wanted to talk about pro
wrestling after practice with his
friends
and he kept trying more sports handball
volleyball
soccer badminton skateboarding so who is
this
dabbler this is roger federer
every bit as famous as an adult as tiger
woods
and yet even tennis enthusiasts don't
usually know anything about his
developmental story
why is that even though it's the norm i
think it's partly because the tiger
story is very dramatic
but also because it seems like this tidy
narrative that we can extrapolate to
anything that we want to be
good at in our own lives but that i
think is a problem
because it turns out that in many ways
golf is a uniquely horrible model of
almost everything that humans want to
learn
golf is the epitome of what the
psychologist robin hogarth called a kind
learning environment kind learning
environments have next steps and goals
that are clear
rules that are clear and never change
when you do something you get feedback
that is quick
and accurate work next year will look
like work last year
chess also a kind learning environment
the grandmaster's advantage is largely
based on knowledge of recurring patterns
which is also why it's so easy to
automate on the other end of the
spectrum are wicked learning
environments
where next steps and goals may not be
clear rules may
change you may or may not get feedback
when you do something
it may be delayed it may be inaccurate
and work next year may not look like
work last year
so which one of these sounds like the
world we're increasingly living in
in fact our need to think in an
adaptable manner and to keep track of
interconnecting parts has fundamentally
changed our perception
so that when you look at this diagram
the central circle on the right
probably looks larger to you because
your brain is drawn to the relationship
of the parts in the hole
whereas someone who hasn't been exposed
to modern work with its requirement for
adaptable conceptual thought we'll see
correctly that the central circles are
the same size
so here we are in the wicked work world
and there sometimes hyperspecialization
can backfire badly
for example in research in a dozen
countries that matched people for their
parents years of education
their test scores their own years of
education the difference was some got
career focused education
and some got broader general education
the pattern was those who got the career
focused education are more likely to be
hired right out of training
more likely to make more money right
away but so much less adaptable in a
changing work world that they spend so
much less time in the workforce overall
that they win in the short term and lose
in the long run
or consider a famous 20-year study of
experts
making geopolitical and economic
predictions the worst
forecasters were the most specialized
experts
those who'd spent their entire careers
studying one or two problems
and came to see the whole world through
one lens or mental model some of them
actually got
worse as they accumulated experience and
credentials
the best forecasters were simply bright
people with
wide-ranging interests now in some
domains like medicine
increasing specialization has been both
inevitable and beneficial
no question about it and yet it's been a
double-edged sword a few years ago
one of the most popular surgeries in the
world for knee pain was tested in a
placebo-controlled trial
some of the patients got sham surgery
that means the surgeons make an incision
they bang around like they're doing
something then they sew the patient back
up
that performed just as well and yet
surgeons who specialize in the procedure
continue to do it by the millions
so if hyperspecialization isn't always
the trick in a wicked world
what is that can be difficult to talk
about because it doesn't always look
like this
path sometimes it looks like meandering
or zigzagging or
keeping a broader view it can look like
getting behind but i want to talk about
what some of those tricks might be
if we look at research on technological
innovation it shows that increasingly
the most impactful patents
are not authored by individuals who
drill deeper deeper deeper into one area
of technology
as classified by the u.s patent office
but rather
by teams that include individuals who
have worked across a large number of
different technology classes and often
merge things from different domains
someone whose work i've admired who was
sort of on the forefront of this a
japanese man named gunpei yokoi
yokoi didn't score well in his
electronics exams at school so he had to
settle for a low tier job as a machine
maintenance worker at a playing card
company in kyoto
he realized he wasn't equipped to work
on the cutting edge but that there was
so much information easily available
that maybe he could combine things that
were already well known in ways that
specialists were too narrow to see
so he combined some well-known
technology from the calculator industry
with some well-known technology from the
credit card industry and made handheld
games
and they were hit and it turned this
playing card company
which was founded in a wooden storefront
in the 19th century
into a toy and game operation you may
have heard of it it's called nintendo
yokoi's creative philosophy translated
to lateral thinking with withered
technology taking well-known technology
and using it in new ways
and his magnum opus was this the game
boy
technological joke in every way and it
came out at the same time as color
competitors from sega and atari
and it blew them away because yokoi knew
what his customers cared about
wasn't color it was durability
portability
affordability battery life game
selection
this is mine that i found in my parents
basement
seen better days but you can see the red
light is on i flipped it on and played
some tetris which i thought was
especially impressive because the
batteries had expired in 2007 and 2013
so this breadth advantage holds in more
subjective realms as well in a
fascinating study of what leads some
comic book creators
to be more likely to make blockbuster
comics a pair of researchers found that
it was neither
the number of years of experience in the
field nor the resources of the publisher
nor the number of previous comics made
it was the number of different
genres that a creator had worked across
and interestingly
a broad individual could not be entirely
replaced by a team
of specialists we probably don't make as
many of those people as we could because
early on they just look like they're
behind and we don't tend to incentivize
anything that doesn't look like a head
start or specialization
in fact i think in the well-meaning
drive for a head start
we often even counter-productively
short-circuit even the way we learn new
material at a fundamental level
in a study last year seventh grade math
classrooms
in the us were randomly assigned to
different types of learning
some got what's called blocked practice
that's like you get problem type a
aaa bbb and so on progress is fast
kids are happy everything's great other
classrooms got assigned
to what's called interleaved practice
that's like if you took all the problem
types and threw them in a hat and drew
them out at random
progress is slower kids are more
frustrated
but instead of learning how to execute
procedures they're learning how to match
a strategy to a type of problem
and when the test comes around the
interleaved group blew the block
practice group away wasn't even close
now i found a lot of this research
deeply counter intuitive
the idea that a head start whether in
picking a career or a course of study or
just in learning new material
can sometimes undermine long-term
development and
naturally i think there are as many ways
to succeed as there are people
but i think we tend only to incentivize
and encourage the tiger path
when increasingly in a wicked world we
need people who travel the roger path
as well or as the eminent physicist and
mathematician and wonderful writer
freeman dyson put it and he
dyson passed away yesterday so i hope
i'm doing his words honor here
as he said for a healthy ecosystem we
need both birds and
frogs frogs are down in the mud seeing
all the granular details
the birds are soaring up above not
seeing those details but integrating the
knowledge of the frogs and we need both
the problem dyson said is that we're
telling everyone to become frogs
and i think in a wicked world that's
increasingly short-sighted
thank you very much